конечно и словарный запас но она она
учительница
я не знаю вы используете системный
сейчас nubar конечно конечно да я у вас
есть несколько вопросов я думаю если вас
больше только не спрашивать вопросы есть
но мы скажем сейчас вот интересно как
формируется задание которые приходят на
e-mail
слава вот эти флэш-карты
да да но и я в принципе потому что я не
знаю детали но у нас есть определенные
ольгу ритм который решает который решает
какие славе и будет
как сказать это имя
вы можете решить 25 как вы хотите и там
вы будете видеть очень ствол новый
который я восхищаюсь сказать если у вас
есть 25 около 60 процентов будет
вещей я имею ввиду он снова потреблению
дарства это это это это не так я забил
будет новый вы только что это уже вы
начинаете понемножку
вспомнить 3 знаете но вы не очень уверен
что вы это не будет вспомнить и статус 4
это не
иди слове принципе вы можете
использовать вы уверен что вы знаете и
вы поэтому есть определенные пропорции
стать из 1
статус план 3 я хочу сказать что
высказал вы сказали что вы вы можете
читать вы понимаете когда вы читаете
английский ну они все так смысл понимаю
о чем идет речь
да да и но вы вы сказали что у вас слова
не запас не достаточно и
я думаю потому что вы изберете у вас нет
возможность много слушать английский или
говорить по-английски и поэтому наши
системы это устроено на принципы это мой
принцип а изучение языка мы должны
много много читать чтобы привыкнуть на
это если n этом языке и и когда у нас
есть достаточно словами запас и когда у
нас много раз много раз
много слышали мы хотим говорить но если
вы нас нет эти привычки не привет
говори запас он поэтому лень это я думаю
это один способ это сделать я мебели
услышать читать и и увеличили словами
запас это способ это сделать очень
эффективный
эффективный это это но я не знаю если вы
знаете все функции мы имеем или у вас
есть несколько трудностей
использовать да нет я вот я я на сайте
уже с февраля месяца и вот в этом ноябре
перешел на платный на базе уровень в
общих чертах я разобрался так ну нюансы
есть некоторые ну например есть люди
которые скажет что трудно искать уроки
вот хотел спросить как как определяется
как перейти на следующий уровень , я
думаю что это это зависит от
индивидуальных когда вы чувствуете что
например уроки на
начинаем немножко
нетрудно очень очень очень легко но вы
можете пройти на следующий уровень
нет правил нет нет но в принципе я думаю
что если у вас вы знаете уже на пункт
например 3 тысяч слов пока что полторы
если вас слова не запас вы же вы должны
прийти на столетия уровня и в принципе я
думаю что потому что наши system link
довольно эффективный я могу например
моем случае я не против читать уроки у
которых есть 30 процент 40 слов кати
реальный знаю потому что я могу лишь
сохранять и изучать но если людей
которые это который не хочет это сделать
не хотят это сделать а не хочет хотят
использовать уроки где только 5 или 10
процентов который маги не знаю но я я не
против под и потому что для меня самое
важное то интерес и на один огда эти
уроки для начинающих очень неинтересно я
у меня есть and dance после несколько
месяцев например например когда я
начинал после несколько месяцев я начну
читать статьи из газет и там был 30 40
процентов который который я не знаю но
это неважно я слушал
никита и
из шаг за шагом это это стало для меня
не не но это зависит от есть мнение это
вопрос по моему очень очень важно и
когда я начинала восковая века я хотела
читать 1 овца я начала читать такла я
хотела читать пронькин style
и у этих романов очень много и у причине
снов слова что я не понимала и что я не
я не было бы читать
уловках но fling дней возможно мощно
больно читать и изучать то что я хотела
изучать и для меня это было очень важно
чтобы сохранить мой интерес
моя я люблю лейки навыки например если
вы мы можем видеть экран и я всегда
скажу дэйзи интерес это я думаю что
концов отношением я имею ввиду что вы
хотите изучать
вы думаете что вы можете вы можете
успешный отношении azik я люблю русский
язык я люблю чешский язык я польский
язык я думаю что и я могу говорить
свободно один прекрасный день это
ощущение это это чувство это отношение
очень очень важно и и поэтому интерес к
таре мы имеем
для который мы изучаем это у тебя пути
возьми когда это скудно до нас я думаю
что потому что мозг это не только рад
все на на это эмоцию надо и если мы пили
мы вы думаете это интересно мозг более
изучая но я хочу отделить наши близкий
рабочие снова пожалуйста я не сказать
что когда мы вредим уроки
конечно один индикатор это число слов
новый слов и тем более новый слов но чем
чудный очевидно но в то же время для
меня если я вижу там есть счастье
навесного
это я хочу это сделать потому что я хочу
узнать этой новый словно
есть только два но вы снова но это когда
вы идете на библиотеке один мяч и я хочу
объяснить это урок урок урок это
вещается странице
уроки не
я имею ввиду там мы имеем например
рекоменду они
уроки и танк решается
уровень и вы можете ночно так начинающий
а потом когда у вас есть вы можете это
изменить на среди но я имею ввиду когда
вы уже использует используйте там вы
можете это свободно изменить вы можете
искать другие вещи кита рессора который
шел дождь и
или но уровень и который библиотека
будет вспомнить это который вы решили в
руки в странице уроки понимаете я очень
трудности но это это я я думаю это один
аспект нашли новый систем вы можете
свободно изменить уровень
но уровень близким и мы называем default
это будет уровень который вы решаете
странице уроки и как я знаю что есть
люди которого у которой
использования наша библиотека является
проблемы попробовал
попова изменились и стал немножко проще
попроще и поэтому там все эти фильтры
который позволяет вам искать нам
например
содержание так стихе 3 который имеет
только больше чем подписан процента но в
основном вы можете это сделать но все
или
уроки которые которые имеют менее чем 10
минут
все это вы можете вы можете определить
accent здесь не хотите послушать
американский акцент и знаю все этого это
здесь но обычно вы не это не видите вы
должен открыть это смотреть и один канон
это зависит от экран есть люди кому они
предпочитают
divided уроки на 1 галлон или но есть
разные вещи в принципе я думаю это
немножко трудно понимать но когда вы
посетите библиотека это это выглядит
одинаково но библиотек это те игроки
которые вы уже не
мои уроки разумеется это делается
который вы уже принял брали на мой ваша
но вы очень или и сейчас мы их не очень
это немножко трудно видеть но уроки
который вы уже импортировали вы можете
видеть поэтому я думаю что но наш дебют
экспорт лучи вы можете искать поискать
вещи и я не знаю экономией поэтому
импортирование уроки нет economy
но если всё таки не хочу на претило
например и скачиваю который имеет
отношения к нам законами там вы можете
использовать поиск дамы можете
импортировать
я не знаю вас есть вопрос есть другие
вопросе ну хорошо потому что там иногда
мы слушаем что вы пьете очень трудно
использовать я не могу искать и найти
уроки которые я хочу видеть но я думаю
что это вопрос все-таки это вопросы но
надо привыкнуть
есть новая функция
крупскую я очень люблю есть мощно
мощно выйдет к фоссы и видеть сколько но
новая слов и ucoz фикус потому что я я
импортировала очень много
halls of что я не очень
чала и тип я я я думаю что можно 1 май к
судну я хочу я хочу изучать hose assy
чем-то новых снов и
им нужно выйдет можно и изба косы и и и
видеть классе
сатива ванне
за червонец основе слов мы будем сейчас
видеть сколько новый содержание baby
т.к. там есть уроки пульс не и и
провести
и там сейчас
у нас смотрим на вы можете этом решить
например только видеть гусей которого
есть 10 на 50 процент новый слов мы
будем в будущее тоже позволить
сортировать зависит от процент новый
слов сейчас вы должен решить 10 между
5-10 но в будущее вы можете сортировать
наибольшее количество новых
усама брошены на весло или наоборот это
сейчас нет но в будущем мы будем тоже да
но и вы можете сортировать сейчас
зависит количество розе и то значит
популярность этой руки и это тоже я
думаю очень удобно страница уроки когда
мы начинаем я нафига например в чашке я
средние и или в корейские
там мы можем видеть уровень средний
уровень
там
уроки которые получила получили
рози это значит что там был по крайней
мере четыре
которые думали что это очень интересно
вот это это я думаю это очень очень
полезен потому что каждый каждый раз
когда мы начнем начнем начинаем там есть
новый урок который
и ползла по плавности но я буду это
сделать это на мой и все этого я думаю
что это помогает люди найти уроки
которые совпадают интересы но я что я
попробовать трудный уроки визу
я думаю что это это это важно потому что
мы мы мы можем всегда
повторять для мозги это не та важно но
всё-таки интерес тоже важно если мы
всегда
продолжаем изучать вещи кита который не
облагается виза для является трудно но
наши прыгаю будет
а не знаю если вы понимаете суть вопроса
хотелось вот реально просто услышать нас
и поговорить я просто удивлен ну
восхищен насколько ваша система это и
вами
как для человеком который владеет
несколькими языками
просто не верится да да очень спасибо но
я потому что я не за дело много
по-русски зуя
я очень до какой степени мои ушки
недостаточно и сейчас я буду сегодня .
заниматься русском потому что я это меня
это не важно потому что я делаю это и
доходы
я думаю что я изучал пешком это будет не
помогает в русском но это ты это это
является проблем но будущее я думаю что
это это не это не важно это это я думаю
что изучение языков это очень-очень это
не только для нас мозги не
это очень хорошо и это очень это
позволить познакомиться с другими людьми
это это фантастически просто
фантастически я очень рад что у нас в
линка в наши маленькие общество
сообщества есть другие как вы
и вы мой мы можем англии в украине в
корр один мы можем общаться сегодня
по-русски и спасибо я хотела сказать что
ты изучал русский легче и быстрее чем я
и я думаю что твой способности
а не к тому что я я могу видеть что я
спас хочу сказать что я не думаю что я
стал я думаю что способность изучать
нахожусь у нас сказано в каждом языке
который мы изучаем наши способность
изучать языки улучшилась и я согласен с
иваном села на и я
поручил вдруг вас один старик сказал что
я хочу помогать старые видение лидер
вещей возраст катаре который имеют
проблем зрения языке
yaz yaz пассивно почему почему вы
думаете что я для тебя что это значит
store
он диктует 40 лет весь мир он будет
помогать
старый но люди старше тем 40 лет у них
такой проблем но я не знаю может быть
они не очень хорошо
слушает я сказал эй дура я думаю что
сейчас меня 610 семь лет но я
мой способ моя способность изучать язык
и язык языка
ну че сегодня ночью тем когда у меня был
я не знаю 16 как иван сказала в каждом
языке который мы мы это способность
изучать это можете тренироваться поэтому
сейчас хотя я говорю русские стройности
и особенности потому что я изучал чашки
и сейчас я не знаю этот частью или
русский
но все-таки это для для морские это
хорошо
ага ну я я я просто я эд я подписался у
вас на google plus я получил кучу писем
там понимаем не только на на русском
языке для получилось и я решил зайти
посмотреть что это такое поэтому я с
вами сейчас
но добро пожаловать мы принесли мы
говорим о изучении ездить мы говорим
языков мы говорим о ли я не знаю если я
на самом деле я вас узнал я как-то нашел
вашу книжку называется я не помню
называется но там очень много оно
сделано так там даже написано в начале
что это не книжка это наборы с вашего
статей с вашего блога это да я читал ее
мне очень понравилось на она написана
очень легким английским языком и мне
идеи понравились который в не написанный
от планет как изучать язык не с помощью
вот этих книжек а с помощью какое-то
живое живого чтение и сама платформа
was- алинке у меня на нравится
удобствами но я немного и пользовался на
деньги у людей использует
бесплатно но там там лимит 100 слов же
там я не могу больше видеть снова но я
введу
разумеется мы предпочитаем что люди один
потому что у нас есть программисты вас
есть много заходы но все таки все эти
статьи и уроки вы можете скачать но
конечно если имеет
я думаю что потому что например на
русском или на чешском у меня есть три
тридцать тысяч снов на мой слова ли
запас на мой базе дали которые сохранят
ее там не очень очень помогает когда я
читаю и там есть много много линков на
горшок желтые алисы underline и этом у
меня помогает и поэтому я хотя когда я
говорю по-русски не а я говорю но до
новой ошибками но слова не запас у меня
достаточно богатый я могу читать но я
говорю ну я думаю что это это для меня
слова и запас это это самое важное вещей
видите ниже к
ну это я понял за книжки ваши у вас
подход такое что он сначала через
пассивный активным дартмут лучше читай
очень слушаем а потом когда появится
желание какое-то внутреннее начинается
самом начинаем уже говорить да а еще
вопрос того им я хотел not wear вы
находитесь в канаде правильном да вы не
думали смотрите вот ваш сервис
предлагает на разных языках это все да
много языков но он примеру
так как стать уровень жизни разных
странах раз на нет ни думали как таунт
например для разных стран с дед разные
стоимости уроков это очень трудно делать
в интернете потому что вы нежны мы не
знаем есть куда
понял я конечно но надо я могу сказать
то наша система может быть кажется
просто очень многие я скажу так я я этом
я нe я сама идти изучаю на самом я сами
я из украины как выданные туда вон сети
учусь мне нужна система для немецкого
языка у них английским не место не
проблема говорить ну я понимаю говорю но
мне нужна система нам на немецком языке
есть порталы как бы русско русскоязычные
созданные но они ориентированы только на
англоязычном для изучения английского
языка
ваша платформа мне полностью нравится
потому что она позволяет учить не только
английский язык но немецкий все-таки
номера но она не такая гибкая что ли как
то что они на классная не только цена
останавливается
я понял он от надо будет созреть и
попробовать может быть надо больше
полугода взрывал прикладным она
заплатила
значит вы вы студент германия я студент
но все не то смотрите тут получится я
учусь на англоязычной а программа да без
немецкого языка в германии это как без
английского
британия
вопрос 11 или
вопрос у меня есть вопрос по поводу
одновременно изучение языков ваш опыт в
этом есть как вы считаете этом бы
сформулировать
получается например и да вот я например
знаю что там английский он конечно он не
идеальный я допускаю в нем ошибки в то
же время я хотел бы сделать его выучить
не его как бы учить его более детально
то есть хотел бы учить прилагательные
например с большей
разное количество и она там чтобы
оттенки показывать языка тоже ремни надо
учить и другой язык немецкий как вы
считаете это они будут друг друга как
там нибудь друг другу мешать или или или
сделать конструкции лучше на одном языке
не пытаться вот такое но сейчас у меня
есть это опыт поэтому вопрос языка
русский а потом решил изучать чешский и
это это это немного трудно потому что
эти языки немножко похоже грамматика об
части в часть чашки а бруски по-русски
очень похожи но есть разница и словами
запас очень отличаются и поэтому я могу
сказать что это блин немножко трудно
потому что я думаю что между
между немецком английском тоже будет но
тем не менее я думаю что это стоит это
делать потому что это будет улучшить
твой босс способность изучать языки
будете через периоды трудности а потом
вы
я думаю что я у меня был случае так им
опыт не не только только сейчас мой
чашки и сейчас мой русский пацан странах
но в конечном итоге
русские части будет я не знаю если это
сделать будет а еще а как ваше мнение к
программам вот течение слов наподобие
орки вы слышали слышали о такой
программе анка я опять опять
есть такая программа anki для изучала
смог к ваше мнение по этому как вы на
стоит ли делать большой фанат и .
хотя у нас потому что у меня есть час
полтора часа я могу я есть один час
времени для изучения языка не за языка
но я предпочитаю читать а слуги потому
что это интересно я не я я не я не думаю
я не знаю у меня есть ощущение что когда
я даю я вижу желтый слов слова в линьки
это это это ведь потому что только это
это не алгоритм это это мой интерес я
буду читать статьи статью о политика
а будет каким образом я не думаю что
у меня есть необходимость
сосредоточиться на прождать но это тоже
потому что у меня есть только один час
но если я буду изучать я не знаю каждый
день 5 часов
но чтобы я думаю что будет больше
использовать анти 1 часть а потом
послушать потом читать но в принципе я
на изучение
я предпочитаю сделать kotoryj не
нравится
наслаждаться если у меня есть 1
я могу наслаждаться я буду продолжаться
и если это скудно я не буду продолжать
для тех кому это нравится но пусть
делать но я не очень люблю использовать
иногда я это сделаю я сделаю я изучаю но
прежде чем я начинаю читать
иногда я буду делать ваш флейте потому
что мы можем видеть это уроки все-все
который я уже
я могу но вот девочка
это определяет что вы должны изучать это
я не хочу систем решает что я должны
изучать я предпочитаю брать один статью
это имеет рисует а ожидать и
и и может использовать пачкать но только
находится сейчас необходим одним вадим
один добрый ветер от у вас очень
маленький когда я начинала с цинком и он
он очень велик ли ты со мной я помогли
маме
хорошо но есть любили
вопросы или комментарии
ok большое спасибо большое спасибо
спасибо развиваю до свидания спасибо